I wanna I wanna get through the rest of
the panel because I think the original
question was was the girl should the
girl have stayed oh yeah
so I want to get YouTube I think you
guys both said leave
did you say leave no I will stay for
like um
I've been treated with them honestly
like I'm honest to you you honest to me
okay like let's do something else you'll
say okay
me
um no she's she's asking than you
um
to be honest I feel like
because he for example the footballer
situation
um
if you're gonna go into a marriage you
shouldn't be having to cheat so then
it's I would leave because I'm expecting
a man to be with him even if he's the
he's the footballer what if he told you
up front
if he told me up front like I'm cheating
yeah I'm going I'm still gone okay
because you've cheated on me and that's
not what I wanted from you is it
cheating if he tells you
are you still yeah you're so cheating
like regardless of what you've done or
whether you're going to do it or
whatever it is
if you have those thoughts you're not
happy with me so well every man see
everyone's got those thoughts I would
bet every dollar in my bank account that
neither one of you would leave Drake
you're both full of no but that
that's just like the greater myself
because why am I letting a man cheat on
me yeah why are you flexing on all your
girlfriends going and living in a
mansion
would be happy about that because if my
girls had happy relationships completely
living normal lives and I was seeing
Drake they'd say Rue yeah you're living
this mad life but he's cheating on you
you don't love exactly it's not real
it's not real well that's why that's why
women keep I like how she I'm sorry I
don't mean that's okay I like how you
let your friends Define your
relationship with your man instead of
thinking for yourself no no that's what
you just said no it's literally what you
just said I'm just saying like literally
what you just said I'm just saying as an
example no as an example you literally
just said I I would disregard how I feel
and take in consideration my friend's
opinion and I'm dating Drake is that not
true I'm dating it doesn't matter it
does matter it matters how you feel
about the situation and I would feel no
but we're gonna get divorced in three
years I would feel the com yeah but I
would feel completely the same I'd be
betraying myself
everybody here said they're in a
situationship before so you've done it
it's interesting because in this case
you get more so you you get you get
everything paid for okay
and and you're married and you're
married to him
um and he does the same thing that the
guys you you have seen before have done
you'll be opposed to Define you like
just because you've done something
before doesn't mean that that's true
you're not gonna like do it you're past
counts with a man I'll tell you that
past the past tends to repeat itself so
I mean if it's something that you say
you don't want to do like you don't have
to do it anymore you're the CH you
decide yeah but men don't forgive you
for your past of course
but I mean like your past doesn't Define
you in the point of no but I mean like
in the point of
um you just said oh you've all been in a
situationship so like why wouldn't you
be in a situationship with someone that
you know is giving you more money no my
point is it's cap like it's it's cap
because everyone here has done it that's
why I don't believe it yeah but then you
wouldn't be looking for love in that
situation I'm saying I'm saying in a
situationship you guys got less out of
it because I'm sure in a situationship
it's you're usually not being taken on
crazy days you're not but then you learn
from it so you choose whether you accept
this like the same reason of a man
so I I know and a girl that are in a
relationship but he actively cheats on
her and he tells her love oh this is
what's happening
she chooses to accept there and move on
at the end of the day that's her choice
she can't come to me and cry about the
situation because she accepts him she
chooses it she chooses that lifestyle
but if she didn't choose that lifestyle
she wouldn't be with him you don't think
it's a choice by dating a footballer
yeah it is a choice so that was my point
when the question
and the question I'm saying was she was
she wrong to leave or should she have
stayed and I'm saying she picked that
lifestyle by picking a guy that is going
to cheat yeah more than like at the end
of the day as you said maybe all Ballers
and all rappers and all these people
maybe they might not cheat but I said
maybe the majority of them do cheat and
do this so what about them individuals
that don't cheat that are rappers or
things you still have to get to know
people as they are right but it's like
this is what women do it's like you're
looking for a lottery ticket that
doesn't exist because it's not you like
the majority of you it's not it's not
going to be you you're not because like
the magical woman that's gonna change
this guy that has always to achieve it
what if Chief Keith doesn't
how come like how what makes like I know
uh some of our opinions differ but like
how come you you think like this like
what yeah do you know what I mean like
why do you think like that why why do I
think that cheating is natural demand
because 8 000 years ago um 17 women
reproduced for every one man so I think
it's actually really common for um and
natural for them to be non-monogamous
I'm not saying that um every guy is
gonna cheat on you I I don't believe
that but what I do believe is that women
go after the men that will cheat and
then they cry about then they cry about
it later and I just don't have a lot of
sympathy like if you're going after the
top 20 percent of that if you're going
after basketball players
um entertainers rappers and you're gonna
cry later that you got cheated on no
surprise oh yeah or even even the top
five percent of men it's like these men
have worked their whole lives to get to
a certain point you weren't with them
when they were broke and now you walk in
and say oh be faithful to me why would
he again it's the problem of it it's the
problem of looking at it in a dignified
way as opposed to looking at in this
sort of sort of more harsh darwinian
sort of um economic Marketplace kind of
a way which is what it really is where
the people are at the top who have the
more opportunities are gonna act on
those opportunities you know these high
value dudes are going to act on the
opportunities that they have because any
guy would every and this is what we're
saying every guy would want to act out
in that way not every guy has the
opportunity to do so but those are the
top absolutely do and they're gonna
they're gonna utilize that for them and
I'll tell you another thing yeah any
goal will take the opportunity to be of
a guy like that exactly exactly exactly
exactly and another thing that happens
because I see this quite a bit myself in
my inbox yeah is the the average guy
that's coming home every night
when he gets cheated on he gets cheated
on with a guy that's that other dude and
he's sitting there being loyal and being
a good man Etc yeah and and she's
sliding in some footballers inbox yeah
and if he bites and she's foolish enough
to believe it'll be anything more than
just sex then she tried she but she'll
probably just do the sex and
at the same time she would leave him for
that footballer yeah it's ugly it is
ugly and I'm not saying I like it but
it's absolutely true it's the huge
majority but it's not the whole of
females the whole of Mills look I'm not
on women I'm just saying when
that guy gets cheated on by because
women cheat to you yeah no of course and
when they do they're generally not going
Downstream to do it they're going at
least across yeah but mostly they're
going up yeah so I mean it is the harsh
reality that's why when he says
darwinistic it's very darwinistic in
that way yeah but it's an important
message because nowadays people people
idolize celebrities in such a way that I
think a lot of women don't don't think
about stuff like this really like if I
it's true just hearing you talk right
now even they're thinking for love when
you're going for a man like that like a
lot of like I feel like the woman is not
thinking oh like this is this man's
gonna love me like I need to be loved
you know I think she's thinking I want
money you'd be surprised
rappers athletes and Ballers as an
example but I see it with the with girls
going after the same guys at school
or girls going after the same like it
doesn't necessarily mean they have to be
famous but I see girls date the same
guys or go after the same guys all the
time and then cry and whine yeah when
they cheat when it's like yeah you're
getting the same result every time
and my issue to is not it's one we're
trying to make amend into something
they're not when at the end of the day
most men if they had women pursuing them
like the top percentage of men do so
these are all like uh there's um
athletes have girls on the side that
that will the like the most beautiful
women you have ever seen nines and tens
begging them to have threesomes you
don't think any man like in 20 years a
man is gonna turn that down or is gonna
turn that down ever even a good Godly
Man
he doesn't
caption I'm so sorry
that's my point even a man that is Godly
like he's still a man yeah no my issue
is when we go after these men that all
the women want and then we're shocked
when they cheat when it's like okay well
why don't you go lower he doesn't have
to make that much money he doesn't have
to be that cute oh well I can't do that
well but do you know what it is
that's something it's so important for a
girl to go through her single season
because I feel like in that season of
just singleness and like reminding
yourself you have to reprogram your mind
of okay I don't I can't go for these
guys anymore and even if you know in
yourself I don't want to go for these
guys anymore any guy that comes to you
that's not like this guy that you've
been going through like going for since
school it's like that ick to you it's
like oh like he's a good man but do you
really want that good man like you know
when girls say he's a good man you're
like oh she don't really like him he's
just good because you know he's cheating
whatever but you have to literally
reprogram your mind and say these are my
morals and I have to stick with it for
like a year did this happen where you
like switched your girls are like I feel
like I'm suing the process of it because
like even some people talk to me now and
it's like oh this is a good guy more
than like you know he's not like the
other one by side
do you actually want that how old are
you again if anyone 20 oh wow yeah how
old did you think I was like 25 oh yeah
okay okay
um so when did when did you switch this
like thinking like you went to church or
something no no I've been in church but
I was always that I wasn't always like
with God for the same but it wasn't this
is not to do with God everything to do
with the people that I've been with and
um I just realized no like you you
preferred the toxic ones like you like
them a little better I think I would
really all like the stage like that yeah
a little face but I feel like it's a
young people thing now if you met a guy
if you had to pick between the good guy
that's in your inbox or this toxic guy
you're thinking of I can see it
you're thinking of someone I don't know
who it is someone someone got you which
is okay every girls had their heart
broke it's like yeah do you know what it
is so it's like even if he won it you
just have to tell yourself that stay
away distraction but your heart you you
would still want the more toxic one I
gotta reprogram my heart no but but if
we're being honest if we're being on
I'll go for it but in my I'm protecting
my heart still I'll still have my boring
soccer I'm like he's not gonna give you
what you want he's not going to give you
love he's going to be doing all the
things that and you don't want and ended
you up in that situation after after
like this relationship or whatever
whatever it was you did you go to church
was that like your outlet
I was going to church regardless no but
I mean is that you seem to have had and
you could correct me if I'm wrong some
spiritual like Journey maybe where
you're praying more or like I don't know
what it was yeah that that's quite a
long story
um to be honest but um
yeah it's funny enough after a
relationship I did get more like
um spiritual and like started talking to
God more and like started like yeah
it's not spiritual it's like a church
it's a Christian it's a no I don't I
don't either that's why I don't call my
like I'm I'm Christian like if I just
need to say it easily but I don't say
just Christian because I don't just say
Christian because I believe I'm just a
woman of God like I just because
sometimes you can say Christian and it's
such a gray area like everyone's
Christian if you go to church if you
listen to your pastor but I believe okay
cool I'll look into my scripture and
actually have a connection with God but
to go back so basically though yeah
you're trying to now reprogram yourself
to like the good guys
um it's not reprogram myself it's not to
be honest I'm not my mind right now is
not on men like my mind right now is
focusing on myself and when that person
comes I'll know the season of singleness
I just want to be single and focus on
myself right now but in the future you
want the good guys in the future I want
the man that's right for me okay okay it
sounded like you said good guys earlier
you said you have to reprogram your
brain so I just to like not like the
people that I was lacking before right
yeah so I'd imagine this is the good
guys right
yeah but not in the yeah
no it's not good guys it's the right man
for me that's it like just that as many
of you know I was just banned on Tick
Tock and we are demonetized on a daily
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible